my name is Anil Chaudhary and I'm seeing
your business manager at cognitive group
I think I went into it not necessarily
having a problem but it was more about I
didn't know that personal branding was a
thing in recruitment I saw in other
industries and no one had ever given me
the option to create my own brand I
thought be really interesting and
hopefully drive sales and money
I've gotten so many inbound messages
from clients candidates not even from a
sales perspective but being like I loved
your video I love the content can you
post about this can you do a video about
this that's turned into organic
conversations that I've been able to
flip into sales so it's a really warm
approach without having to cold call a
lot of random people
I think personal branding is an amazing
tool to really get your name out there
and whatever industry you work in I
think recruitment is one where it aligns
so closely to it but people think oh
well my business in my brand I work for
Hays I work for this I work for you know
whatever a big company but really you
are the brand so being able to work with
the likes of yourself somebody who
understands it someone who is able to
help craft what persona you want to put
out there has been amazing I think
anybody whether your first year
recruitment or ten year veteran can
benefit from that
you